je bouge pas d'ici je te regarde alors
tu vas ou d'attendre un peu à ce manager
[Musique]
adjoint
il
m
lassant
[Musique]
atteint
heures
tiens
soleil
à cette fâcheuse ans d'exp nantes
[Musique]
et tout entier à charlie août un surnom
genre tu écoutes choquer ou non c'est
tout court non monsieur c'est juste
charlie charlie d'accord tu t'es déjà
fait arrêter non monsieur bâlois de
sortir jusqu'à une heure mais en fait tu
rentres à quelle heure disons deux
heures deux heures c'est pas une heure
un charlie non mais sérieux tu dois
rencontrer pour une heure
t'inquiète je pas de la police en une
semaine tu te rases combien de fois
combien de dijon 104 4 x 4 fois par
semaine des point click et les seahawks
pourquoi pas parce qu'ils sont super et
une fois où je manger un burger richard
sherman s'est servi dans mes frites
c'est top
j'ai tellement envie d'être une fille
normale mais si je vais au soleil je
risque de mourir attend ça diraient
qu'on fasse un truc un séjour je suis
libre le soir
[Musique]
avec lui je ne suis pas qu'une maladie
c'est trop romantique ça me dégoûte le
sec je lui en ai pas encore parlé
timo la vérité je sais qu'il souffre
ivre
tu a transformé ma vie cathy
[Musique]
oui ça diraient qu'on fasse un truc un
séjour je suis libre le soir équipe
vraiment séides
ça m'ennuie beaucoup qu'ils soient pas
au courant
qu'est ce que j'aurais dû dire si je
suis exposé au soleil je risque de
mourir
c'est très sérieux tati tu peux
m'expliquer s'il te plaît non n'est pas
un homme qui blesse quelqu'un dans sa
vie
y'a pas mieux
[Musique]
je fais souvent le même rêve je sens le
soleil chauffe et ma peau et des bras me
sers et tendrement j'ai envie de rester
là pour toujours mais c'est impossible
j'ai une hypersensibilité à la lumière
du soleil
les rendez vous chez le médecin font
partie de mon quotidien il n'y aura
jamais de rémission et chaque année qui
passe augmente le risque alors je reste
tout le temps à l'intérieur derrière des
fenêtres adapté jeu bord le jour je vis
la nuit et je fais de la musique et que
j'en ai l'occasion
guy salut
qu'est ce que j'aurais dû dire salut je
m'appelle katie price a fait dix ans que
je t'observe depuis ma fenêtre je suis
amoureuse de toi et je te soutiens en
permanence
c'est le truc de taylor swift elle a des
histoires compliquées et elle en fait
des chansons géniales
je comprends pas qu'on soit jamais
croisés je passais devant chez toi tous
les jours on a longtemps traîné ça te
dirait qu'on fasse un truc un de ces
quatre je suis très occupé la journée
mais je suis libre le soir
qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire il ya
tellement de choses que tu m'emmènes à
ton premier concert
so sérieu sert des meilleurs moments de
doute
[Musique]
tu viens
ça m'ennuie beaucoup qu'ils soient pas
au courant j'ai prévu de tout lui dire
mais là je suis quelqu'un va juste une
maladie et j'ai besoin de ça dure encore
c'est pas quelque chose que tu pouvais
me cachais suis déçu mais on n'est pas
un couple qui baisse les bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas mieux
[Musique]
j'ai attendu toute ma vie de ressortir
ça